one state department official tells CBS
News quote Saudi Arabia lied and feels
cornered over khashoggi disappearance
Turkey's justice minister said this
morning his government's investigation
will wrap up soon Holly Williams is in
Istanbul with the latest on that inquiry
Holly good morning to you
good morning Turkish forensics
investigators searched this building
last night the Saudi Arabian Consul
generals residents here in Istanbul
Turkish officials have told journalists
they believe Jamarcus Abdi was killed
after he walked into the Saudi consulate
16 days ago but some unverified reports
have suggested that his body may have
been disposed off here at the Consul
generals residence investigators are
expected to search a forest and a
farmhouse today according to Turkish
media the New York Times is reporting
that US intelligence agencies are
increasingly convinced that Saudi
Arabia's Crown Prince Mohammed bin
Salman is culpable in her Shah jees
disappearance several of the Saudi
suspects identified by Turkey reportedly
have links to the Prince including one
Maha Abdul Aziz mreb who apparently
accompanied Mohammed bin Salman on his
us visit this year and who was
previously assigned as a diplomat in
London some reports which we cannot
independently verify also have grisly
new details about that audio recording
that Turkish officials claimed they have
from inside the Saudi consulate
including allegations that her Shoji was
tortured and his body later dismembered
Norah Holly Williams in Istanbul you're
right the u.s. waiting for that
intelligence as well